An American drone strike in Afghanistan targets and kills Mullah Fazlullah,...
...the leader of the Pakistani Taliban.
In Greece, demonstrators outside parliament in Athens...
...protest a recent agreement with the Republic of Macedonia...
...to change the neighboring country's name to Northern Macedonia.
In China, a Hong Kong university research team...
...claims it may have found a "functional cure" for HIV...
...after testing new antibodies on mice.
In France, Italian Prime Minister Giuseppe Conte...
...announces during a meeting with President Emmanuel Macron...
...that Italy will present a new proposal...
...to overhaul European Union immigration policy.
And finally from England, late physicist Stephen Hawking...
...is laid to rest in Westminster Abbey next to Isaac Newton and Charles Darwin.